hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the
absolutely central concepts in George
Dickey's discussions of the nature of
art in essays like what is art and
institutional analysis and what is an T
art is what he terms the art world now
he did not originate this term and he
acknowledges that is taking it from
arthur danto but his analysis is
attempting to go a bit further than that
and make it absolutely central as the
basis for defining what art actually is
going beyond previous failing theories
such as the imitative or expressive
theories of art and to go past the
impasses of the mid 20th century worries
about whether we could define are at all
now Dickey does not think that he's just
playing with ideas here he thinks that
he's actually again following donto
analyzing social realities that are
quite complex an entire network that
comprises this this you can't call it a
thing
you may have to call it something like
an atmosphere that is the art world and
so he says although he doesn't attempt
to formulate a definition arthur danto
in his article the art world suggested
the direction that must be taken by an
attempt to define art he says to see
something as art requires something the
eye cannot describe an atmosphere of
artistic theory and knowledge of history
of art an art world and then diggie says
well this needs some elucidation what
are we talking about here
not on the exhibited properties complex
properties rather than simple properties
he says that is absolutely central and
he says in speaking of atmosphere in
history Don Jose remark carries us a
step further he points towards the rich
structure in which particular works of
art are embedded he indicates the
institutional nature of arms and this is
what Dicky thinks is is a really
significant contribution so he begins in
this essay what is art by talking about
whether this exists or not and he brings
up the case of George Bernard Shaw who
uses this metaphor of an apostolic line
of succession stretching from Excellus
to himself
Ashlin is one of the earliest Greek
tragedy in so one of the great
contributors to early drama George
Bernard Shaw is writing from the vantage
point of his own presence now our past
and he's saying there's this line in
apostolic succession
what is apostolic succession well that's
a theological notion that's being used
metaphorically here and it means that he
can trace himself back to someone who
can trace himself back to trace himself
back and it goes all the way back to the
originators presumably the Apostles in
this case the nationalists Sophocles
Euripides you know the ancient Greek
playwrights maybe with Aristophanes
thrown in there as well but your
strasser you liked his comedy as well
and the idea is that there's some sort
of continuity of the art form being
carried up we can talk about you know
philosophical schools having had
successions you know think about the
early plainness and Aristotelians and
Epicureans and the Stoics they had their
school arcs the people who were in
charge you know promulgating the
teachings and running the school and
then you know people said I learned from
so-and-so I learned from so-and-so now
in the case of Shaw of course he's not
actually like learning from people who
learned all the way back it's it's
rather reading and participating in in
institutions that way so if we look at
theater though Dickey says that the
tradition may have run thin at times and
perhaps even cease to exist altogether
during some periods but it was reborn
out of memory and the need for art the
institution was associated with the
theater theater and varied from time to
time in the beginning it was Greek
religion in the great state and medieval
times the church more recently private
business of the state national theater
but what is remain constant with its own
identity is the theater itself with an
established way of doing and behaving
primary conventions and so you know we
can say the same thing not only about
theater he says theater is only one of
the systems within the art world each of
the systems has its own origins and
historical development and we might say
that we actually have more systems now
then perhaps Dickey did at the time of
his writing and Dickey perhaps more at
the time of his writing that in the time
of George Bernard Shaw I think about how
important film had become by the time
that Dickey is writing these these works
so he says that one central feature that
all these systems have
common is that each of them is a
framework for presenting of particular
works of art saying this is art take a
look at preferring are bringing it
forward for whatever it's going to be
the spectator the appreciator the
listener the reader to to appreciate and
to note as being arms what they don't
bring forward presumably then is not art
or at least it's not art that they're
bringing forward perhaps they're relying
on somebody else to do that instead so
this is a very important idea the art
world is a whole bunch of systems that
are connected together and each of them
furnishes an institutional background
for conferring status on objects within
its domain he says no limit can be
placed on the number of systems that can
be brought under the generic conception
of art each of the major systems
contains for their subsystems there's an
elasticity involved here and again we
might think about things that nowadays
are considered art that perhaps before
we're done so you know in our time and
where we have these incredible
supercomputers that we use for a large
part for gaming
well you know games video games can be
considered works of art and they in fact
incorporate and assimilate other domains
of art like music and illustration and
drama so you know there's there's some
interesting things going on there so
we've got this this bundle of systems
another key thing that he points out
about the art world is it's not as
formalized as say the world of law
people always want rules for how to do
art and then we say things like well
rules are meant to be broken
and then people break the rules or like
that like yeah that's not a very good
breaking of the rules
that's that looks like garbage to be or
that sounds like crap right well you
told me to break the rules yeah break up
like you know in music we're thinking
about why don't you break the rules rock
and roll like like Lemmy did but don't
imitate lemming exactly so we provide
these things why do we do that well
because the art world is not just a
system of highly codified rules there is
innovation there's creativity there's a
lot of fluffy as well but you know you
have to use rhetoric to get people to
actually buy into what it is that you're
doing there are some things that are
formalized norms and then there are some
things where other factors are involved
he holds out the possibility that we
could have a extreme formalization but
that would stifle creativity it gets
more interesting when we think about
well who and what is this art world what
are the constituents of it so he talks
about core personnel and this is really
something he says that the court
personnel in the art world is a loosely
organized but nevertheless related set
of persons that includes the following
but it's not simply restricted to the
following artists which would include
painters writers composers producers
then we have the people who actually
present it right which include producers
might also include people who are taking
other people's art and nesting it within
their own also within the producers of
the museum directors museum goers
theatre goers those would also be in the
governor's part
reporters for newspapers fit in there
and so he says that the the essential
core is the artists who create the works
presenters who play some role in
presenting the works and this doesn't
mean necessarily just putting it up a
wall or placing the website it could be
also the people who make sure that the
artist gets paid who organized the
gallery openings all of those things and
then we have this vast field of goers as
a constant entice they sprayed their the
appreciators the people who come in and
say oh that's good
so let's take a typical gallery
exhibition of paintings make it very
straightforward and simple the artist is
the person who's produced the paintings
the person who's running the show and
the attendance required those are the
producers and then the general public
coming in and sipping the wine and
eating the cheese and looking at the
paintings and saying that reminds me of
an orange or hmm I wonder if this is a
statement about class dynamics or that
makes me feel blue any of that sort of
stuff those are the goers and all of
that is part of the art world and you
know different people can put on
different hats so an artist may produce
somebody else's show or go into
galleries and appreciate what's going on
there a musician let's say a talented
guitarist is definitely going to be
going most likely to other people's
concerts and being out there the
audience being like then you rock and
then later on with other shows that guy
sucks
it can't solo to save his life right all
of that is part of the art world and you
know we can also think about all the
people involved in the production of
instruments the media that are used for
the Fine Arts so the people who actually
produce pigments in the case of music
the techs who come out and fix the
instruments that people who sell you the
instruments all of them would be part of
there's other people who are involved as
well
critics of art historians of art
philosophers of art journalists - we
could say really anybody who is not
doing the art and is not simply
appreciating or consuming but has
something to say about what's going on
would be part of the art world as well
and then he says two other things that
are that are kind of at odds with each
other
at least on the surface one of these is
that all of these roles he says are
institutionalized and must be learned in
one way or another by the participants
for example a theater goer is not just
someone who happens to enter a theater
he is a person who enters with certain
expectations and knowledge about what he
will experience and an understanding of
how he should behave in the face of what
he will experience this is something
I've talked about in terms of music with
a couple of friends of mine when you go
to a metal concert if people are not
standing up and you know giving the
horns and you know pumping their fists
and stuff like that or banging their
heads well you got a problem if you go
to a classical concert and you know WC
comes up and it's a particularly moving
you know passage and you start getting
up and thrashing well they'll throw you
out of there right so there's different
ways of behaving in different areas of
the art world and then we can say the
same thing about painting and sculpture
and all sorts of other things as well
including theater so there are some
institutional roles right but then
interestingly Dicky also says there's a
kind of more democratic participatory
aspect to this as well at one point he
says every person who sees himself as a
member of the art world is thereby a
member now does that mean that
everybody's on exact
same level so I wandered into a gallery
and I'm like I can appreciate paintings
let me have my like you know wine here
and she's you know a nice little hors
d'oeuvre here hmm let me look at this
and we start just you know saying crazy
crap right I'm not necessarily going to
be taken as seriously as somebody who
has Greater stature within here well
because these are institutional roles
but there's nothing to keep me from
actually coming in or if I don't want to
come in maybe writing a blog about it or
watching videos or anything like that
there's one other feature that's really
important to this notion of the art
world and that's that of machinery not
discussed at great length in what is an
art but discussed at more length in what
is antique art so what is the machinery
of the art world he says that all the
things that are required to present
works of art museums concert halls art
galleries theaters walls of houses all
the things that are you could say
institutional receptacles or tools are
part of the machinery of the art world
which would include a large part of the
Internet at this point as well so this
is this rather amorphous conception of
the art world and by providing these
points of analysis we can wrap our head
around it and get a better idea just
what it's supposed to consist in and be
according to Dickies analysis
you